mientras las autoridades sanitarias de
países bajos se apresuraban a poner en
cuarentena a los pasajeros que llegaban
en vuelos procedentes de sudáfrica el
viernes la variante omicron ha circulado
en su territorio el instituto nacional
de salud pública confirmó que encontró
la variante omicron en muestras de
pruebas tomadas el 19 y el 23 de
noviembre antes de que sudáfrica
compartirá la noticia de la variante con
el mundo las autoridades neerlandesas
aún no saben si las personas que se
sometieron a las pruebas habían visitado
el sur de áfrica aunque el origen de la
variante sigue siendo desconocido eso no
ha impedido a que más de 30 países se
hayan apresurado a imponer una nueva
oleada de restricciones a los viajes
sobre todo a los procedentes del
continente africano
españa se sumó a la larga lista en el
día de hoy concretamente lo que hemos
adoptado es un acuerdo referido a la
restricción de vuelos procedentes del
cono sur de áfrica alrededor de 10
países europeos han confirmado al menos
40 casos de la variante omicron al igual
que la isla francesa de la reunión
mientras vuelven los mandatos de
mascarilla
identifican las campañas de vacunación
los investigadores del laboratorio de
sudáfrica que halló la variante trabajan
sin descanso para saber más sobre ella
este es probablemente el virus más
mutado que hemos visto es un
frankenstein comparado con otros siempre
hay algo nuevo es decir el virus no deja
de sorprendernos los científicos están
especialmente interesados en descubrir
la eficacia de las vacunas actuales
contra la variante omicron